أحمد صالح هارون أنا مخرج
تشادي أنا في كان من أجلي
ابن جي في المنافسة الرسمية
[موسيقى]
الخط كمبدأ في تشاد هو عليه
ومن المعروف جيدا أنها قيمة نحن
أسهم جميع والتي تتكون من
نساعد بعضنا البعض على أن نكون متحدين في الأخذ
اعتنوا بشؤون بعضكم البعض
المجتمع في الواقع لذلك هو
المبدأ التشادي حقا هو
التضامن ليس قليلا كما هو الحال في كل مكان في
ويعتقد أن أفريقيا من هذا القبيل
إنها تأتي من فكرة بدأناها في ذهني
وأنواع الروائح تظهر هناك
الفيلم
أنت تعرف إذا لم أفعل ذلك
لا أحد سيفعل ذلك
أنا فقط أشعر أنني مضطر لذلك
افعل لأنه لا يوجد أحد آخر
كما تعلمون، الأمر كذلك
عندما يحترق المنزل وأنت كذلك
الوحيد الذي يملك وسائل الإطفاء
النار لا تستطيع أن تقول فيها
حقيقة أنه ليس منزلي لا أستطيع أن أفعل ذلك
افعل ذلك ولهذا السبب كنت أتحدث
أن تضطر إلى ذلك في الواقع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
استمع هناك الكثير من الشباب أنا
تجد في الواقع لا بد لي من ذلك لا أستطيع
لا تكن متشائماً فأنا كل شيء
فقط متفائل عندما أرى الجميع
هؤلاء الشباب الذين يحلمون بصناعة السينما
أنهم يفتقرون إلى التدريب
ربما أفتقر إلى الوسائل ولكنني
قل لي أنه عندما نريد أن نفعل شيئا
الشيء الذي يجب علينا أن نخترع الوسائل معه
والتي يجب أن نكون قادرين على ممارسة و
هذا هو اختراع هذا الاقتصاد
تفتقر إلى
عليك فقط أن تفكر في كيفية القيام بذلك
اخترع اقتصاد الفيلم الخاص بك
نعم، أنا دائما أقول ذلك في الواقع
في كل مرة تتاح لي الفرصة لذلك
التحدث مع الشباب حول التدخل مثل
أنه في تدريب جوردي لتمرير
من خلال الصحافة لأنه كذلك
أجمل مدرسة في الواقع هي الفن
لتعلم الكتابة لتجميعك
تعرف كيف تصل إلى هذه النقطة وهذا
الكتابة هناك تضع الكثير في الواقع
أيضا لفن رواية القصص في الواقع لأنه
ما هو نفس الأدب في الواقع
هناك العديد من همنغواي من بين آخرين
كل ذلك أخيرًا هناك العديد من كامو و
أنا مار، إنهم صحفيون سابقون
إنها في الواقع قاعدة للجميع
ينبغي أن تفعل الصحافة بالنسبة لي
العام ليصبح في الواقع بكل بساطة
شخص جيد هنا يتفوق فيه
الانضباط الذي اخترناه
[موسيقى]